Jake:就像昨天的那个一样可以吗
Jake: Just like the one yesterday, is that okay?
Lucia: 啊procred有录屏的
Lucia: Oh, procreate has screen recording.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 虽然我没有带iPad
Lucia: Although I didn't bring my iPad.
Lucia: 所以没有办法用procreate了
Lucia: So I can't use procreate.
Jake:没关系
Jake: It's okay.
Jake:没关系剧组报销一台
Jake: It's okay, the crew will reimburse one.
Jake:哈哈哈没有没有
Jake: Hahaha, no, just kidding.
Lucia: 真的吗
Lucia: Really?
Jake:假的
Jake: Fake.
Lucia: 那我现在立刻就下单
Lucia: Then I'll order it right now.
Lucia: 这个软件我都买了
Lucia: I already bought the software.
Lucia: 我可以先下到新的那个上面
Lucia: I can just download it onto the new one.
Alice:这个软件可以买一下吗
Alice: Can we buy this software?
Jake:没有没钱
Jake: No, no money.
Jake:这多少钱
Jake: How much is it?
Lucia: 9哎现在98了
Lucia: 9, oh it's 98 now.
Lucia: 68吗不是
Lucia: Wasn't it 68?
Lucia: 88好像 98不记得了
Lucia: 88 maybe, or 98, I don't remember.
Lucia: 我买的时候对是个8结尾的数字
Lucia: When I bought it, it ended with an 8.
Lucia: 但是具体多少我忘了
Lucia: But I forgot the exact amount.
Lucia: 我也记得是个8结尾的数字是干啥的
Lucia: 就是那个
Jake: It's for that...
Lucia: 嗯可以画画哦
Lucia: Hmm, you can draw with it.
Lucia: 其实也可以做动画哦
Lucia: Actually, we can also make an animation.
Lucia: 但是我水平太差了做不了动画
Lucia: But I'm not good enough to make an animation.
Lucia: 哈哈这位妹子应该可以
Lucia: Haha, this girl might be able to do it.
Lucia: 我她选那个
Lucia: Should I call you in Chinese or...
Lucia: 我应该叫你中文还是叫好
Lucia: What should I call you?
Jake:应该叫你什么
Jake: What should we call you?
Jake:我也没整明白
Jake: I haven't figured it out either.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 薇薇
Tasha: Tasha.
Jake:薇薇
Jake: Tasha.
Tasha: 薇薇
Tasha: Tasha.
Lucia: 好的薇薇应该可以
Lucia: Okay, Tasha should be fine.
Jake:薇薇是吗
Jake: Tasha, right?
Jake:好嘞微微
Jake: Got it, Tasha.
Jake:可以问问管家
Jake: Can we ask the housekeeper?
Jake:就是这边的人
Jake: You know, the people here.
Jake:能不能帮你把
Jake: To help you with...
Lucia: 哈哈哈试图偷盗一些灵感
Lucia: Haha, trying to steal some inspiration.
Jake:帮你帮你
Jake: To help you, help you...
Jake:把床给卸了
Jake: Move the bed.
Jake:把这个床给挪开
Jake: Move this bed out of the way.
Jake:知道能不能
Jake: I wonder if they can...
Alice:哈哈哈偷
Alice: Haha, stealing...
Alice:做作业中
Alice: Doing homework.
Alice:我们俩房间不太一样抄不了
Alice: Our rooms are different, can't copy.
Jake:一般抄作业
Jake: Usually copying homework...
Jake:是别人做完的抄吧
Jake: Means copying someone else's finished work, right?
Lucia: 这个从过程就开始抄
Lucia: This one starts copying from the process.
Lucia: 就万一被老师问到
Lucia: So if the teacher asks you...
Lucia: 你就跟他说出来你是怎么做的
Lucia: You can tell them how you did it.
Lucia: 哈哈也是
Lucia: Haha, true.
Jake:也是
Jake: True.
Jake:对我们先下载那个软件
Jake: Okay, let's download that software first.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 呵呵呵
Tasha: Hehehe.
Jake:连户型一起抄是吧
Lucia: 哈哈哈户型抄不了
Lucia: Haha, can't copy the floor plan.
Katrina: 行抄不了
Katrina: Yeah, can't copy that.
Alice:然后直接直接从淘宝把图片下载下来
Alice: Then just download the pictures from Taobao directly.
Alice:然后贴上去
Alice: And paste them.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 也可以
Tasha: That works too.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Jake:我这房间我是装潢完了
Jake: I've finished decorating my room.
Jake:我是
Jake: I...
Lucia: 哈哈你就赛博朋克风
Lucia: Haha, it's like a cyberpunk style.
Alice:就你赛博风
Alice: Yeah, like a cyber style.
Jake:赛博朋克风
Jake: Cyberpunk style.
Jake:确实装饰了我一晚上哈哈
Jake: I really decorated all night, haha.
Alice:没关系哈哈
Alice: It's okay, haha.
Jake:更赛博了
Jake: It's more cyber now.
Jake:更睡不了觉了
Jake: Can't sleep even more now.
Alice:好累啊想洗澡了
Alice: So tired, I want to take a shower.
Alice:洗
Alice: Shower.
Jake:现在呢行啊
Jake: Now? Sure.
Jake:可以啊去吧
Jake: Go ahead.
Jake:下班吧
Jake: Let's call it a day.
Alice:现在这个能点了
Alice: Now this can be clicked.
Jake:下班吧下班吧
Jake: Let's call it a day, let's call it a day.
Alice:手机呢
Alice: Where's my phone?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Alice:在这
Alice: Here it is.
Katrina: 关机
Katrina: Power off.
Katrina: 进入休眠状态
Katrina: Enter sleep mode.
Jake:可以下班
Jake: We can call it a day.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Jake:今日杀青
Jake: That's a wrap for today.
Katrina: 唉我这断了吗
Katrina: Sigh, did I disconnect?
Jake:没有断但是没关系
Jake: No, but it's fine.
Katrina: 他怎么显示
Katrina: How does it show?
Katrina: 呃呃哦哦可以断
Katrina: Uh uh oh oh, it can disconnect.